hello and welcome to Michelle McDaniel
after dark ladies I'm sure you have
heard because there is an epidemic going
around men are no longer approaching us
women apparently men are sick of it men
are sick of the whole Instagram girls
taking videos of them in gyms or any
other time that they glance at them and
they are done talking to us so this is a
follow-up of a few things that I noticed
from my last video of the woman that was
in the gym talking to herself set up a
whole tripod has a microphone and
everything and a man lands at her for
three seconds and she flipped her a few
comments that I got and I always get
this whenever we talk about you know
igirls freaking out about a man staring
at them I get some of you men and I love
you guys but you guys are always like
well this is why us men don't go up to
women anymore this is why all of you
guys just judges we can't even open
doors for you anymore because of women
like that so we're done you guys are
probably wondering why I have Abba and
preach in the thumbnail that's because
when I looked at their video that's
something that ABBA or preach said I
still don't know their names or which
name goes with too when I watch that I'm
preach he's up yeah sorry sorry if
you're gonna wear the black ones preach
and the blacker ones have the one who
gets [__] preach the one who gets
more [__] Abba
you guys know right all right all right
it's literally Abba and preach it goes
It goes left to right
preach that's why we literally stand
here because it's just easier not
because oh wait that's the same yeah
never mind yeah Abba preach it's
literally in the photo album preach if
it was the other way around I would have
said preaching Apple you get me a lot of
people don't like this this whole
approaching thing put that [__] out the
window
I'm gonna say it now
take it and throw it in the trash women
don't complain hey men don't I don't
give up and I got a lot of that in my
comment section from you adorable men
men should stop looking at them stop
talking to them and ignore these [__]
treat them like they are not there see
how they like it and you know me I
always have to say in my opinion about
little things that catch my eye and I
have to say what are you men talking
about as a female born female got the
goods down here I have not noticed a
decrease in the men coming up to
Michelle the section of my life in fact
I've noticed an increase and I I
personally would think that it would be
decreased with the amount of men saying
we're just not going up to women anymore
okay this is like people say it's
snowing where I am because it's knowing
where I am global warming doesn't exist
what are you talking about just because
you don't see it as a hyper attractive
woman you kind of look good just because
you don't see it doesn't mean it's not
actually happening you you have to think
what are the stats out right now how
many people are actually checking out of
dating if you look at all the studies
men as a whole have been checking out of
dating in in large numbers in fact this
has been one of the most recent findings
what is it 69 of men report being single
where only 34 percent of women report
being single it was like four to 51
percent of men takes they lost all
interest in dating altogether in large
part because it feels unwelcoming
because they feel like so it doesn't
matter what your personal experience is
even if you want to go off of that what
the numbers show is that men as a whole
have been approaching a lot less and the
very few times that they do choose to do
so they just do it on online dating you
know like it sounds like you guys are
trying to start a movement you just
don't want to talk to women anymore I'm
with me when I'm out of the house I want
to get out and get right back in but as
a woman I haven't noticed a decrease I
don't want to like sound like I have a
very big head but when I go out I
usually get talked to so I'm just trying
to figure out who who are you talking
about like what men don't go up to women
anymore because I have not had an issue
in fact I don't think any of my friends
or women in the comment section of that
video and possibly this video how
noticed a decline lady speak up have you
noticed a decline of men not talking to
you stop right there some of you women
are like Michelle I never get talked to
it's okay I would talk to you I thought
you said it's okay you're ugly
I thought you bout to rip her audience
that was that was about to be great
though but at least the women who you
know people tend to come up to you and
compliment your appearance have you
noticed like a decline I have not and
I've been talking to you an array of
women my mom just called the other day
she's 60 years old and young men older
men will come up and talk to her I've
talked to a lot of my older clients so I
control this 30-something-year-old
talked to me yesterday the sports this
older man talked to me the other day
there's no decline I don't know what I
think you guys are just saying certain
things to make you feel better or maybe
like frighten us women like oh no okay I
want you to think about this
the ones who are harassing you probably
don't care about being labeled thus much
as a race the ones I'm talking to or the
dudes who are actually half decent but
don't know how to progress or don't know
how to move forward the ones who are
very nervous about the Prospect and try
ones and never want to try again I'm not
talking to the average dude who's
sitting on a construction site Lord all
right baby you can't talk to those
[__] losers I'm talking about the
average man who doesn't do this you have
to imagine the guy who went up to you
and felt that comfortable that's not the
average man the average man does not
approach women I know this because I see
all these nerds like I don't even know
how to say hi to a girl I don't even
know how to say anything to girls so the
ones that you're talking about are the
hyper either like socially [__] who
don't give a [__] about any social cues
or the guys who want to make you
uncomfortable they don't give a [__]
they want to they're gonna call up to a
respective those are not the people I'm
talking to usually in public I don't
really have time to have a conversation
I go to the grocery store in the gym two
places I don't normally stop and have a
full conversation with people here's the
thing I'm not buying it I'm not buying a
human that saying you know this I'm just
I'm just not going to talk to women
anymore I'm just done I don't I don't
believe it leave it especially if
there's someone that's very attractive
put together you are I feel like a lot
of guys will just be kind of drawn in
that direction or at least you know
okay guys so guys who are watching right
now okay there's a small portion of you
that's seeing attractive women and have
the courage enough the vast majority be
honest do you guys have the balls to go
up to a woman you think is very hot and
say hi to her or to say anything to her
I get DMS every single day from guys
being I have no idea how to talk to him
I'm too scared I think I'm gonna look
stupid that's most of men and that's how
I think women don't understand the
experience of men they see themselves
being bombarded with attention and think
all men are constantly after them not
realizing of The Men Who approach them
there's maybe a hundred other who
noticed her and didn't say a word or
didn't have the courage to come up to
them you know like when a woman's a hot
woman's in a club she'll have like guys
coming up to her throughout the night
best believe there's a whole slew of
other men who didn't have the boss to go
up to them and that's most immense and
they got noticed if you were visited by
four guys in one night
most guys saw you most got in that club
saw you but you got four guys that came
up to you that means that if everybody
that noticed you and thoughts you were
attractive actually went to you it
wouldn't it would have been a lineup who
would have been alive it would have been
a whole last lineup you would have been
the we'd have to change you'd have to
change your face with the bathroom sign
how about I tell you this the first guy
went down up to you got shot down the
other ones went they're not gonna be me
yeah other people know I want to
maintain my self-esteem
when one guy approaches a girl you have
to understand that we act like we don't
know this we know this and we try to see
where this [__] is going and I could
tell you there's some people okay
there's after the guys are going to be
like
God damn it worked and other that other
guys that are not able to approach are
gonna be like
yeah you get that boy do it for me have
one stroke for me bro you don't have one
stroke for me you know what you know
what my roommate he's a performer and
he's worked as a bounce
your money
yo can you put on a shirt and come here
real quick
[Music]
just answer the question okay this guy
just woke up so he doesn't know what
we're talking about okay okay let me ask
you real quick
you weren't you worked at nightclips
yeah you've been a performer yeah you
watch people in the nightclubs
approaching women all the time yeah tell
me when you're in the club do most guys
have the courage to go up to women
there's a certain kind of guy generally
who goes up and approaches women you see
it in the club you can tell the
difference right yeah and you also see
okay when you're in the club and you see
a woman reject a guy do you think you
see that
why do you think most of the guys don't
approach the women
um rejection they feel the rejection
yeah so they don't go
and that's it then answer your question
that you said
once you see one [__] get rejected
me I'm gonna try it anyway so
I mean
you're seven foot nine yeah
anyways yo my roommate is a Dancer I'll
put up his Instagram below if you want
laughs hey everybody yeah you're not
allowed to come over though glad you
don't invite any of these ladies
but the thing is the thing is yet once
one guy get rejected there's there's
some guys are going to be like yeah let
me go in it's my turn I'm going to use
something else so when she says this and
like I don't believe that men wouldn't
approach a beautiful woman it's because
you don't understand the male experience
and this is not me coming at you to try
to chew off your head I think most women
don't understand the male experience the
same way I think a lot of men don't
empathize with the fact that for women
the reason why they're so defensive in a
nightclub when 10 dudes come up to them
is because those women are tired of
being approached sometimes they just
want to be with their girls sometimes
they're just tired of being looked at as
a sexual object so when 30 40 50 dudes
approach them after the 50th one's like
yo get the [__] away from me and it's
understandable we're having a thing
where we're not understanding the others
experience and then we're arguing
against the caricature of what we
perceive them as rather than the reality
which is most men are lonely and lack
the courage to approach a woman and you
have to understand that for a woman
that's what I understand you know I mean
what I had to look out for yeah can you
worked at a club yeah yeah okay as a
bouncer yeah the thing that you have to
understand is that the the club
experience
for women
is it's men and women but women is very
different right it's aggressive yeah a
club is aggressive loud music you don't
know what because of the loud music you
don't know what's gonna you like your
sense
or a big disturb right so someone rub up
on you touches you that it's very
aggressing like especially if you don't
like you know you don't honestly have
the power to
there's a little bit of fear in there
whatever what not so on top of that you
got people approaching you like hey
what's it could be very it could be a
lot so that's a re that's where the
rejection also comes from it can come
come from because experience can be very
aggressive if you walked around Walmart
I have not many people looking put
together it's one of my comfort areas of
oh I can look like [__] because everyone
else is so I'll blend in but honey when
I don't blend in at Walmart and I
actually get all like this this little
18 year old man I guess I'll call him a
man I feel like he's a boy still but
what's chatting me up minimal run to
open doors for me like I said I don't
want to sound like look at me so many
people doing my bidding but it's just
something that I wanted to talk about
because I see all these men in my
comment section Evan preached a lot of
guys that talk about you know the girls
in the in the gym you know upset that a
man is talking to them saying I'm never
gonna talk to somebody this is why we
don't open doors anymore and you really
want to say chivalry is dead it's your
fault I haven't noticed that silvery has
been dead I've noticed in increase the
freaks I feel like I should just do a
compilation of tick tocks of women
complaining that men don't approach them
anymore can we talk about how good men
will sometimes not approach a woman that
he's interested in simply because he's
trying to be respectful and he
definitely does not want to be seen as a
creep
why do pretty girls sometimes never get
approached like they're terrified
they're terrified
every time I'm put together every time I
feel confident tell me why no guy would
approach me and what they mean when they
say men don't approach it anymore it's
not that no man approaches anymore is
that meant that they actually find
endearance because much like you said
the people who approach you when you go
to Walmart or when you're on public are
generally ugly unappealing dudes so when
people say men don't approach me is the
people who actually have things going on
in their life it's mostly going to be
the generous we're going to come up to
you why because men who have their [__]
together understand one is generally not
worth the risk to go up to women whether
you like it or not if I actually have
something to lose I'm not going to spend
most of my day trying to approach laser
going up to them or chatting them up why
because I can go on Tinder and probably
get much better results at a safer pace
so when we say men don't approach women
we're not talking to degenerate losers
who spend all day at home doing nothing
we're talking to people who have
something to actually lose by fear of
women rejecting them loudly or being
really aggressive or calling them a
creep those are the actual men that
you're scaring off I'ma talk for me I
didn't say that people are not
going out more I said that you shouldn't
you shouldn't I was agreeing with you
know what stop going stop doing that
stop going out there and be like yeah
I'm gonna try to hit you up at the gym
don't do that GO train at the gym don't
do that oh I'm gonna try to I'm gonna
try to hit you up at the um
don't do the approaching get your [__]
together work out do your thing better
yourself
and people around you would come up I
guess but the going out thing
don't do it yeah uh but other than that
that's it from us do you think Michelle